okay we all for those joining us on the
live stream this is a one of a long
series of meetings about language
completeness and consistency for from
language and so let's launch into it um
okay so the first issue is we now have
this lovely thing called success what
are the main places that's used so if I
say send mail hello
it'll come back with hopefully failure
oh my gosh
that
well let me deal with that let's say
that wasn't what I expected here but
normally what's another example of
something that returns success entity
prefetch I think is the other main
[Music]
consumer or returner of success objects
okay
so let's say I say I don't know what I
can do here entity prefetch of something
really obscure like amusement park rides
about amusement parks there should be
fairly few of those oh my gosh there are
19,000 of these crazy things I hope
we're going to standardize these boxes
soon by the way decision were you
involved with the books that that
standardization of those money currently
blocking entirely we had a meeting and
both Sushma and I have asked him several
times to do what he promised to do it
that meetings but so okay well maybe it
needs to be somebody else but I'm not
even that keen on these thinner boxes
which I don't think I liked that box the
way we just saw that okay anyway so
that's what happens with the success
thing okay um okay fine all right
functions that should return a success
object right so right so we went through
and the inventory it sort of X trait so
this is really for external sorts of
operations right because you know if
you're actually computing something you
return to result of the computation no I
don't think say for example prints
should suddenly start returning success
every time you what about create
directory no I just returns the
directories or anything stupid
yeah yeah right okay so these are things
that have no return value yes either no
return value or it does resource submits
return right now I would have thought
would return some kind of handle to what
you submitted that returns a right now
it returns a resource submission object
which has no documentation and we don't
know what if anything can be done with
it but it seems like I think that's what
it should return I mean I know that you
don't know what can be done with it
you have to toast the resource system
group that's gonna be a complicated
thing where you can do things like say
oh I'm giving up on the submission I'm
updating the submission and so on I
don't think that should return the
generic success object okay well then
resource submission object should to
have some documentation because it's
true for Brad and Bob and maybe we could
take that to them okay good
all right delete file so currently
returns null unless right if there's a
syntax error it returns on evaluated I'm
not sure what it does if you you know
try to delete something which doesn't
exist so dollar failed right so these
could easily return success instead of
null on on success success and failure
oh this this on failure should return
except I'd I'd hate to break all the
codes that's checking for dollar failed
well yeah
is there code checking delete file for
dollar failed I'm sure there is I'm sure
there is I'm sure I've written code that
does that why what's the purpose of it
because you're trying to error check
your delete file certainly things like
rename file are gonna are going to check
for dollar failed because you needs to
do something if the rename failed we've
had cases where rename file would fail
if you were moving the file across
partitions for example yeah and so then
you'd have to change that to a copy file
in the delete file and then you'd want
to make sure that all okay
fine but so the point here is I mean
returning successes I mean you could
make the same argument you might have
checked for null previously why wouldn't
you have checked for novel previously
yeah you might have right so right well
I think that sir I think that dollar
failed returns sorry dollar failed you
know sort of a natural thing to check
for I don't think that null is such a
natural thing that's a weak argument if
I might say so I mean well that's also I
mean dollar failed carry semantic
information I don't think null in this
case carry semantics look I think you've
got to either bite the bullet and say
it's gonna return success and failure or
we've got to leave it as it is right
well but I think I do want it to issue a
message and return failure because
certainly people are checking for
messages yeah yeah yeah no I think it
should return a message yes I think it
should give a message so what will
failure tell you beyond the message
right I mean failure was intended for a
case for things like interpreter where
it's not going to issue messages but it
you know it tells you you know this
doesn't make any sense and gives you
additional information about why it
could we inventory we're dollar failed
is returned I mean there's probably a
bunch of funky cases of that look I
think this is not the highest priority
thing to change but I think we either
have to decide we're going with success
and failure or with null and dollar
failed let's look at some other cases
here okay and I think I mean delete
object it's possible we could have
delete object start to use this more
modern stuff
same deal I mean look delete object is
the modern form I would feel less bad
about changing that to success and
failure maybe that's what we should do
okay
leave delete file for now but expect to
come back to that okay okay let's look
at six run process and so on
what is run process returning right now
so run right run process start starts a
process to completion and then returns
various information about it no it
should this is what it should return
because you've got to be able to index
into this right I mean you can index
into a success object right if we just
right if you just took out of one and
wrapped it in well I guess you'd want
the first argument it's kind of ugly
I mean you could do you could just write
but my point is so so take out of one
and I think I think you need a tag for
success so take care of one and put it
in an input cell
and then now rap I'm trying to remember
if we require a tag for success or not
but they which I think we do
so that do success you know put in some
string and percent right ok so now if
you do percent you know 64 yeah I say so
I mean unless it's you know it's I'm
gonna reflect back to you something you
said to me whenever I want to put in one
of these special output forms you say
why are you hiding the language yeah I
mean well there's a you'll notice that
this is under the maybes I'm just yeah
well let's go through these I mean that
would that is very nice-looking but I'm
not sure I don't know yeah a bit surplus
to requirements I'm not sure this is
right
I think okay let's look at kill process
so kill process currently returns
nothing and which is a bit unusual right
because so for example when you crazy
when you add a task when you end a task
you get the task object that you
successfully ended back so then you can
query whatever remaining properties it
has so it should either return the
process object that successfully killed
which isn't there anymore right but the
world it's not running but the process
you'll notice was killed but that you
can still query properties of the
process look at the first basic example
there you your frigging weird it what is
it doing is it sending it again
I believe it's and I'm not sure if it's
sending us again to or a cig kill
probably secure the kill maybe I mean
but but even so I don't understand so
this
process object here so let's look at
this this is that yeah it just you see
that where it said process object 0
that's wrong okay so there's that thing
so now I say kill process of that and
that's crazy right so it should either
return a success object or it should
return the process object now the and
the let's take a look at percent one
what does percent one say it is now what
the hell's that start time what the hell
is that
that's probably should be converted okay
now why doesn't this say that that
process is dead my father did so I don't
know that that would be a question for
Garrett
but you'd notice that you can query its
process status right you can do process
status of percent one yeah so right and
you can query I think I think for the
extent that there's anything left in the
buffer or you're right there was any any
output that hadn't been in yet or
whatnot you can still access it so I
think probably it should return to
process object but that's good question
sure yeah did the process finish or was
the process killed or is there actually
shallots it's got a it's a shell with a
you know that's waiting for whatever it
is sent right well I think it was
actually killed and which procedures
suggest it was sig kill rather than say
can't
can somebody see if they can get Garrett
you can ask him
well we'll loop onto some other things
here let's loop back to this okay all
right so connect well that's interesting
because what Cloud Connect returns right
now is the name by which you logged in
right oh right
yes I wrote down server which is wrong
but yes it gives I think success for
that would be good because I think we
will be nice to give some other
information there mm-hmm like the server
my proposal is that that should return
success object okay right so actually
there there actually is no notebook save
as the the the device what about things
like this like device to configure that
was not on our list for some reason I
don't know why that's just frigging
weird what that's returning that's just
crazy weird yeah I think that would be a
very useful thing to return success and
probably some other things with devices
if there's an initialization that will
be one I think should return success -
okay somebody has got like seashell
seashore type background noise hi we are
asking about kill process um
the and the question is when you kill a
process what first of all what is its
ending is its ending stick kill yeah I
believe it's ending take and then there
right now it's not documented but there
is internally yeah okay the it sends a
specific signal and then okay all right
fine
the question is should kill process
returned a success object or should it
return the process object does the
process object still mean something
even after kill process it doesn't mean
very much it might still have
information about what it was you might
be able to do some queries on it to tell
whether it still is running can't you
drain standard output or is standard out
lost if you know is just gone from the
process table is it standard out the
process has gone from the process table
yeah the process should be gone from the
process table but if you still have the
object you might still be able to drain
the standard out right presumably we've
still got the information about the
process that we had in the exit code
that kill process recorded and then sort
of thing
great so does the process object record
an extra code no it doesn't because it
actually isn't a process object it's not
I think it does good great code here
mm-hmm
there's let me show you what happened
here if I do that and then I say kill
process of that and then I ask for that
process object again it's it's it's
turned into all of that weird stuff
right there's a lot of information that
can look at so the start time went
bonkers there you see that that's just
yeah yeah that's pretty clearly a book
but you there's the process status why
doesn't the process status show up in
the process object there's a couple
pieces of information that just haven't
quite made it into here's what I think
should happen with kill process I think
kill process should return a process
object but that in this in this display
one of the early things above the fold
should be process status right and
actually I just realized why it should
definitely not return success but rather
the process object because if you send
to stop you would definitely want to be
able to continue playing with it okay so
that's the conclusion kill process
should return the process object the
process object should should display its
process status above the fold great
perfect world it might even have some
cool icon that indicates whether it's
running or not there is there was the
question about the exit code you can get
the exit code from process information
there's a function so maybe we can
display that as the start there was I
think we even decided to actually do
this it just got buried behind other
projects right to change system process
to change process data to sub values
right but
that's a status excuse me
but right now sorry it's not processed
data it's process status yeah I think it
should be a sellout
we having that as a complete function
it's kind of well it's now a committee
we're committed to it as a complete
functions or whatever we have process
information why isn't that just a sub
value on the process object and its
legacy in it we have a task already
right now to kind of move this
information into the generic information
object yes so what is the status of the
generic information object by the way
[Music]
well it's I mean they don't know that we
have anybody to work on it at this time
I thought you were working on it no hump
did it did it die on the vine somehow I
mean it was it was next project and then
Nick you know yes
sir could you check into that it needs
to be pushed a little bit more yeah okay
all right so back to this so there may
be some cleanup associated and please
don't forget to rerun this example here
because it's wrong see that yeah I think
we do I think somebody needs to make a
sweep through all of the process link
pages and reevaluate them clearly yeah
David okay all right let's keep going
um okay I think that's it what we were
talking to Garrett about unless somebody
has a further point here no right so
notebooks save and notebook open
apparently there's a symbol notebook
safe as but no documentation and neither
John nor I know what it actually does so
we can ignore that middle one but these
are really just interfaces to the why
isn't it return the file name because it
is really I mean it could right now
right it's really an interface to the
front-end right i profoundly think it
should return the filename okay okay
notebook open returns the actual
notebook notebook open no no no that's
right no book open is a side-effect it
opens the notebook right yes notebook
save should return the father but
notebook open so what the hell does it
return or unless it returns to notebook
object that's what I'd expect but it
doesn't look like it from that example
although there's a semicolon there so so
if you delete the semicolon in the next
input weekend so it does return the
notebook object okay so yeah and then
right so if and notebooks save I think
should return right I'm just saying it
right it'll bring up the chooser at
least in an unnamed and absolutely then
once you've chosen it should it return
the file name or the notebook object
I think the file name right because
that'll persist this even if the next
thing you do is notebook close maybe
maybe that was maybe that was the Droid
we were thinking about notebook maybe
that's a type of there and that should
be notebook closed right because
notebook closed is I think currently
returns nothing there must be it
somebody on the live stream is
suggesting that maybe we need a function
to detect and eliminate background noise
in these clothes is the one that doesn't
return anything and this and this could
return with clothes returned what is
clothes clothes stream return stuff that
was yes of course that was a pretty no
on my part analogous thing for notebook
closes that should return the notebook
that was closed
right I guess yes was closed so does
that still exist
yeah the notebook object is no longer
valid and so they suppose it could no
that's right because notebook close of
no arguments is the currently open
notebook making sense so and that would
not have a name string to stream oh my
gosh this is so horrifying
who who is making that seashore noise
okay look I don't think we don't hear
anything just yeah neither do I so well
it's not me for sure because I'm in my
usual environment which is walking along
the beach right right yeah I don't know
who wrote these basic examples I guess
he didn't want to create a temporary
file but normally returns to filename
the reason it's returning string there
right is that it created the string
stream rather than close should return
the analog of that file name right which
right which if it was a save notebook
exists but if it wasn't a safe notebook
then I don't know yeah right but like
that string thing is an example of a
weird thing being returned so the
question is what's the weird thing it
should return
for notebook clothes for the current
notebook I think I think that would be
the don't book title as a string I'll be
totally weird because you couldn't
distinguish that from her look this is a
return file of a path to notebook for a
saved notebook and the string name of
the notebook for one that wasn't safe
that's a hack I mean it cuz for files
we're not returning the file object for
closed we're not returning a file object
right but that's because close predates
the file object I'm aware of that but
explain that to users um this is not you
know look this this isn't a great story
here yes I will just point out that
again these were on there under the
maybe these are things that looked like
they might fit in with you it will be
good to do a pass through all of these
things and I don't know it's hardly an
urgent thing yeah let's ignore this
right now okay
let's continue character name and
private Unicode space oh this is a
horrifying area right not private
Unicode space is horrifying
- okay right so we had a conversation
and we decided that well let's take an
example of something the wolf is in
private Unicode space isn't it yep so
you right you need to put it in quotes
and then from character code or
something or sorry to character code I
said the wrong one okay so it's up in
private Unicode space yep what's the
question here right so we had the
conversation about character right of
that - character name of an alpha
and we're happy it's an alpha right now
let's do character name of the wolf it's
real name is Wolfie um but we probably
don't know that how did it know that oh
I know what the issue is right because
this is right because character name
returns to Mathematica long name the one
argument form so what happens when you
add comma Unicode name that's the the
issue right because character name gives
the the mathematical um name that should
be not applicable private-use area or
something exactly so so the issue was
that there's no way of distinguishing we
don't know what it is or it just doesn't
have a name from it doesn't make sense
because it's in the private Unicode
space and I I was hoping that character
name would tell me hey this is in the
private Unicode space rather than my
having to go to so we write so we write
so that was the starting point of the
conversation and we agreed on that and
then we agreed that it's gonna give
missing not applicable right right and
so then there was this question about
entity character you know character
entities or instance I think that's the
right way of saying it right so if you
do like control equals lowercase Greek
alpha right that should okay let's
actually there's another question that
this question on the live stream from
sander here asking about supporting
emojis what is the status of the non
plane zero unicode support we now have
internal support for that so I I was I
was actually looking into that today
with John so the kernel we have a
version of the kernel which understands
non planes zero
Unicode Unicode which is you know
probably needs some polishing but it
basically works and it does the simple
things so that means that to character
code will return numbers greater than
65,000 correct great so then now we the
issue is that right now there when those
characters get sent to the front end the
bits
higher than 16 get lost so yes so if you
want to know the gory details basically
so it would seem to be like it just the
front end was calling the wrong WS CP
function and you know that it should
just update the WS DP function then when
it did that there seemed it seemed to
expose some sort of bug in WS DP so
needs to investigate further before we
can must be a ton of other functions
like import functions that and the
binary reads and all kinds of other
things that are binary reading Unicode
and assuming it's plane zero Unicode I
would think well binary read doesn't
interpret well I guess it does it has a
thing called Unicode string means zero
Unicode string I don't think it has
something called Unicode string they
think it has something called string
which means take each byte and turn it
into something 0 to 255 and has
something called
[Music]
and it has some and it has character 8
in character 16 that's all fine
they need to carry needs a character 32
now presumably right which is one of the
things as I pointed out was missing from
the pull request
so whether that fix now or later I mean
it's it's what about binary formats that
we can read binary formats like I don't
know whether Excel I have no idea if
that's even a binary format these days
whether it's some XML non binary format
but but if it anything that is a binary
format we should worry about whether
it's dealing with non plain 0 unicode
right so I think the the answer to that
question is we'll need to test it right
because it depends on how right I mean
if we're directly parsing the bits are
ourselves then fine but if we're calling
some library then we need to check how
are we transferring the data between
write the library anyway it didn't that
sounds that's great
yes it's definitely emotion and in the
front-end if you've got tools to be able
to type in emoji for example like on
your phone that's good that that code
path is going to work is that true that
is the open question I mean the theory
is that for example if I go to the cloud
app ok this is this is a fairly ornate
path right they go to the cloud app I
use my you know mobile phone emoji
keyboard I press an emoji it's a picture
of an elephant or whatever weird thing
you have in an emoji nowadays and it
special wolf I bet they have wolf emoji
I should look um anyway so I've got my
wolf emoji that goes through then
through the app through the cloud app
over HTTP to the cloud does that path
work
somebody has somebody looked at that
part I'm sorry I got a loss in your long
path can you say it again no I'm sure no
one's looked at that path because we
don't have that kernel on any of our
cloud servers well though they only have
an internal server running the prototype
build
so if this is in the prototype build we
could look at this right it's been then
the prototype build as of a week ago I
think okay fine well somebody should
look at this then I guess it would be
the cloud QA people maybe all right I
can share with right I mean the the use
cases I type a wolf emoji on my phone
into the cloud app that's case one case
two as I type it into a browser right
mm-hmm at the cloud and then the
question is what ends up in the kernel
is it a wolf emoji is it not is it a big
splatter bits right which I think to a
certain extent depends on on how are
things being transferred between the
cloud and the kernel right somebody sent
a wolf emoji in the in the live stream
here also asking about zero width joy
knows anybody know about but I don't I
don't know that name if they can provide
us an example I can zero with joiners I
think are what are used to like say
create combo emojis
I see so like at least on iOS you can
select the sent the skin color for you
know a man or a woman emoji well
something else okay well I mean there's
also the case which we've never
addressed which I hope we're going to be
addressed in languages like c'mere for
example that have these totally weird
diacritical marks that have hats and
feet and other things on their
characters which is I think a different
issue anyway that's that's a separate
thing yeah well we have react well zero
with juniors exist in our in basic are
in in the basic multilingual plane
and so you can all read me don't
apparently we don't have a one name for
it but we do have the but do we have
correct behavior for it
oh yeah that's a separate issue but we
can look at that that's a separate issue
look let's come back to this issue about
character names so okay so we agree that
this is under what should it be called
private use area I don't even know
whether that's the right term for it
that is the the official Unicode name
PUA private use area okay fine
right all right that's fine now what's
the next question so then the next
question is then there was a broader
question of how do we expose so well a
do we have but also be up more
importantly from a design perspective
how do we expose Unicode blocks and is
that its own function is that only an
entity character entities and and so
forth
so we need to create the character
entity and see what its properties are
okay so if I say to entity of that
alphabet I should get a character entity
right that would make us and that's not
what the heck is that I think to have
got a character entity we really should
figure out by the way what is that what
is that what the heck is that who is
making the seashell noise I think it's
Hewitt I okay so this doesn't even
contain the unicode block right yeah and
it doesn't have the it seems to have
cracked at that funky thing no we had
that yeah
that yeah well it's not clear to me that
that's even really I mean it seems to
have basically nothing about the you
know I'm not even sure that's a valid
entity what's coming out here right
because so if you do control equal Greek
small letter alpha character you get
something that looks completely
different
okay well and also let me note that this
isn't an alpha
that isn't an alpha right so I think
something has gone horribly wrong in two
entities there okay so that's a bug okay
so then let's if I say control equals
small Greek alpha yes okay so that's a
character what pack is this oh look at
that oh but it's that really weird thing
okay so that's just something totally
weird with two entity right that's a bug
into entity okay all right okay so here
if I say that it's taking forever why's
it taking forever oh okay what's that
Greek and Coptic that's the name of the
Baloo okay so that's the unicode block
okay fine
so if how do you get the unicode block
if the thing isn't an entity great okay
so here's my suggestion what is this
thing here this thing is going to say
this is a named entity right of type
character what the heck is that
what is
char Oh 3 B 1 what is that that is that
is the standard name right which is
identifying it as a character and then
the hex value but why is it okay this is
something for Toni and I don't know who
worked on character data maybe Francisco
right because that's what I mean what I
would say that what we should do is to
actually have that thing that is
something like entity if it's in private
Unicode space why not have I mean I
admit this is a little bit bizarre but I
mean you know what we were seeing before
there was something like this right
totally weird I mean there's there's
some scrambling here but I don't think
that's the people involved to unscramble
it's the people who worked on character
data right so I guess my claim is right
so if we take Wolf's and do it in you
know look at it in hex and then you know
stick that into the entity right so we
edit the out of 96 with with you know
ff7 to 0 that should so it doesn't know
anything about or at least it's not
formatting I suspect I suspect it only
knows 5535 ok right so I guess the
question is sure that I mean look I
think this is a very roundabout this is
ok this kind of entity manipulation is
very similar to what we talked about for
molecules that is there are certain
known molecules that known as a whole
infinite collection of you know
constructible molecules and similarly
here there's 2 to the 32 constructible
characters which slowly over the course
of
I'm will be filled up like the Egyptians
did with various hieroglyphic wolves and
so on it's really only two did a21 but
is that right yeah at some point they
decided the promise that they'll never
use more than two - the 21 Wow okay Wow
which is still a lot I know but that's
you know the artists of the world can
come up with more emoji than that mm-hmm
that's kind of stupid actually if you
ask me but I mean it okay in any case no
matter so the question is I mean it
could be that all of those two million
if we really believe the two million
number which I don't believe mm-hmm I
think it's gonna extend then we could
imagine something where each one of
those two million is an entity right or
we could decide that characters okay
wilmut as you go beyond playing zero
Unicode there are perfectly fine unicode
blocks like there's ones for Akkadian
and stuff like this right great and the
emoji are they categorized the emoji is
standardized right between a you know
different kinds of mobile phone right
the emoji are the same yes yes so yes I
mean I don't know if they all live in
one block or the exact technical details
but yes I mean the the Unicode
consortium spends a distressing amount
of time on you know standardizing emoji
instead of finishing up all the actual
human languages okay interesting how
these things evolve okay fine I mean
we're gonna wind up with some whole
weird thing where we have linguistics
for the emoji do we have that I think we
do have that in mouths mouthful we have
some emoji linguistics
like a wolf emoji and stuff like this
okay so what's the point here so the
point is what do you actually want to
get for these I mean look if the emoji
of categorized we might as well have an
entity for everything up to the to to
the 21 right which I think I mean they
think they're only using you know a few
hundred thousand at this point but yeah
but I think inception we should support
as sort of computed entities which is
what we've been talking about in other
words this is a finite blob it's not
like molecules where there's an founded
collection okay so I think we should do
these as computed entities when we have
that notion in entities store so I think
that's not a difficult notion here we
should have that as computed entities of
type character and that's if you want to
get the unicode block that's how you do
it you form the entity and then you ask
for the unicode block property now
should there be a more direct way to get
it probably not right now I don't think
it's our most important feature does
that make sense to people
I think Jeremy who should probably opine
but they think that makes a certain
amount of sense Jeremy
yeah I mean we can look into it what the
hen that's probably that's probably even
an Allen thing he absent right no right
that's a traditional form of missing is
this old line okay oh all right so we
don't have a cliff for that that's
really hard
how do we come to have a tooth for that
other thing why don't we have a glyph
that's another Allen question and one
enough is that what an earth is that
that's crazy
whatever that is is completely nuts
another Allen complaint yes okay all
right fine so is that everything we had
to talk about on this some character
name question right so basically we
needed an action plan about how to
access unicode block and sounds like the
answer is yes through through these
computer entities right okay right so
this was sort of something this is a
long-running weirdness yes and so let's
not discuss that here function object is
probably the most promising of new
things we discussed right let's talk
about prom character code and byte array
what's that about right so right now
[Music]
from character code does not accept byte
arrays right
and because we have fighter a to string
and then so they're there right now of
course that okay that used those as the
right so that took that those bytes in
utf-8 and converted that to a string and
right so it's a slightly tall string
because you the last character there is
a newline
now if you try to do by trait the string
of percent 105 comma unicode it will
yell at you and that's because we don't
yet really have a way of right unicode
isn't doesn't know what to bite only
what what bites exactly so then the
default character encoding for from
character code is unicode so on some
level we you know that was sort of the
decision there's a round tripping thing
here if we go from character code so
let's say we say range 900 to 9:20 okay
and then we say from character code of
that right now
that thing arguably is that's a string
now how do we make a byte array out of
that well so we can use string to byte
array which will give that needs a
character encoding right so that's doing
it you'll notice that's much longer
because it's in utf-8 oh I see and this
is just gonna give complete garbage know
that that's going to work because
they're both the they both defaults to
utf-8 so right the counter argument is
right so so the given given that bitrate
the string doesn't currently understand
unicode the you know that's sort of why
we don't support it and from character
code the alternate the counter argument
is that you know you could do binary
read list or read byte array and get a
bunch of you know single bytes at which
you want to interpret as as you know
single bytes to be fed to from character
code
and so if you if you use the one
argument form of from unit from
character code that'll interpret them as
0 to 255 code points and and give you
the essentially the ISO Latin characters
of those what is the problem we're
trying to solve it so one point is that
within our own strings we try and
optimize things so we're not using up
you know if the string is just regular
you know I so Latin it's not using whole
giant corpulent you know non plane zero
Unicode with things for those characters
right exactly
I mean we're essentially using an
internal slightly customized version of
utf-8 internally so for for pure ASCII
we're using one byte per character and
then we use more for higher yeah right
the question is so there so I guess the
problem so I guess the question is does
you I guess the question is does Unicode
to need the that's the character
encoding Unicode need to be consistent
between byte array to string and from
character code is really the question
and as so the argument that they don't
need to be consistent is that we you
know they're sort of on some it already
unicode already can mean multiple things
coding our unicode is a hack yes think
that really should be multiple different
things like utf-8 unicode etc etc right
so right so then
that is very weird I miss someone on the
livestream is pointing out that maybe
the Greek letter the letter we got
wasn't a Greek alpha but I think it is
because escape a escape is a Greek alpha
so far as I know yes it is it
corresponds to the due to the Unicode
code point for for alpha or at least for
one of the Unicode code points well what
do I do here if I say unit code name
yeah yeah that's that's so that's big
small letter alpha well I'm confused
something went wrong with that entity
945 um right so I think perhaps the the
the most sort of reasonable thing to do
is that Unicode and or at least a a
reasonable thing to do is that
inviteright the string unicode should
mean something sensible like you know
you you know you I think the ultimate
best thing right thing to do is to break
up this thing called character encoding
arrow unicode and actually turn it into
the four different things that might
mean well before is plus or minus two or
something yeah I was going to say I
think it's probably more than fine but
let's figure out what it should be like
unicode utf-8 like you know all those
kinds of things right let's figure out
what that should be rather than try to
continue the hack of just saying
character encoding our unicode okay
right I mean there is one there is one
there is a one situation in which
character encoding goes to Unicode
actually makes sense although I suppose
you could replace that with utf-32 which
is communication over WS DP because if
for a link for link object saying don't
do anything to the characters treat them
as code points that was I mean that's
almost character encoding arrow well
it's not none because it wants to take
them in 32 byte 32 bit
right right or or it's a separate thing
maybe you could think about this what
should we turn the Unicode character
encoding into okay and then we'll worry
about after we know what that is we'll
worry about what the thing called
Unicode ends up being you know which one
of those that ends up mapping into a
mutt circumstance okay sounds good
all right well thank you very much
thanks to folks on the livestream thank
you for your comments and until the next
time okay